si tiene una fractura por compresión de
uno o más huesos en su columna su médico
puede recomendarle un procedimiento de
vertebroplastia o cifoplastia su columna
vertebral tiene cinco secciones
principales tres de las cuales son la
columna cervical en su cuello
la columna torácica en su pecho y la
columna lumbar en su espalda inferior
cada una de estas secciones tiene huesos
separados llamados vértebras la parte
que alberga el peso de cada vértebra es
llamada el cuerpo vertebral su cuerpo
vertebral tiene una cubierta exterior de
hueso compacto
y una red interior de hueso esponjoso
poroso
si tiene osteoporosis el hueso de los
cuerpos vertebrales puede volverse más
delgado más poroso y de esta manera más
débil
y agacharse estornudar levantar objetos
o caerse puede producir más presión en
su columna vertebral de la que sus
cuerpos vertebrales debilitados pueden
soportar
comúnmente las fracturas por compresión
ocurren en la zona de transición desde
la columna torácica más rígida a la
columna lumbar más flexible
y la presión puede provocar una fractura
por compresión en la cual su cuerpo
vertebral colapsa
para reducir su dolor primero su médico
puede recomendar tratamientos no
quirúrgicos estos tratamientos incluyen
descanso medicamentos para el dolor y un
corsé para la espalda
si estos tratamientos no funcionan su
médico puede recomendar un procedimiento
de vertebroplastia o cifoplastia antes
de cualquiera de los procedimientos se
colocará una vía intravenosa
usted puede recibir antibióticos a
través de la vía intravenosa para
disminuir las probabilidades de
infección se le dará anestesia local
para adormecer su espalda además la
anestesia general puede ser utilizada
para mantenerlo inconsciente y sin dolor
durante el procedimiento
si recibe anestesia general se le
insertará un tubo respiratorio por la
boca y a través de la tráquea para
ayudarlo a respirar durante el
procedimiento
su médico hará dos incisiones pequeñas
en su espalda sobre su vértebra
fracturada
un tubo hueco llamado cánula junto con
un instrumento puntiagudo dentro del
llamado trocar será insertado a través
de cada incisión en su cuerpo vertebral
fracturado su médico utilizará una
máquina de rayos-x de tiempo real
llamado futuros copió para guiar la
colocación de la cánula y el trocar
si se somete a un procedimiento de
vertebroplastia su médico retirará el
trocar y luego inyectará cemento óseo a
través de cada cánula para endurecer y
estabilizar su cuerpo vertebral
fracturado
si se somete a un procedimiento de
cifoplastia su médico insertará primero
un pistón de balón a través de cada
cánula antes de inyectar el cemento el
balón en la punta de este dispositivo
será inflado para restaurar la altura de
su cuerpo vertebral después de desinflar
y remover el pistón de balón su médico
llenará el espacio creado por el balón
con cemento óseo al final de cualquiera
de los procedimientos su médico retirar
a cada cánula
y cubrir a las pequeñas funciones en su
piel con una banda estéril
después de cada procedimiento su tubo de
respiración será retirado si se utilizó
anestesia general
usted será llevado al área de
recuperación para ser monitoreado
y le darán medicamentos contra el dolor
si fuese necesario
usted puede ser dado de alta el mismo
día o dentro de un día después del
procedimiento